Let's start with the simplest case.
That is, we have a one-to-one association and
we're always going to traverse it in a single direction.
We can do that with a simple pointer.
Instances of class a are always going to refer to instances of class,
exactly one instance of class b.
And we're always going to go from the direction from a to b.
You just have a simple pointer, which means in an object-oriented language,
we have an attribute of the target type in our, in our class.
Okay, this is quite simple to do.
And it even extends in the case where there might be multiple instances in
the target class associated with a particular instance in the source class.
In that case, instead of just using a simple pointer,
we use a vector of pointers.